H  PTOVA
YIAVE,F COURSE, R DAYS BEFORE T
ADMINISTRAT TART WIT.
WITH THIS NEING.LLG
DETAIL OIS.
NEW DETAN THE ROLESOR STN
HANDLED THEPE I RorTO LTIPLE FH
RUSTRATIHA
SL OA VI PROCESSS CONT
TOP ADORT ORTED STFROMHA YY POIR
HIS HARD LINE VIEWAT
FOR THE F THIS
WHITE HOUSE IN
ISN
T Y BUNCS AND SANDROTRY? D WAN
WHO COUNITEDTERTICULARLY AFGHANS
HALF OMENT AND ARER WORKT STILOS
TALLED THIS Y CUMBERSOME PROCE
CIAL TOLD , WE LOST ND
ON SHOO E F THESREFUGEESUNFORTEL
REALEVED TO STILTAN AN
KATE.
U SOH THAT. BS
HEAT F F CLAIMING THAT
RESPONDED TO C FACECISNES  DETAF
IS.
DANIEL, WHAT IS
SANG THIS?
SAGKINGNGO, YOU KNOW, THELAN  E
T AHINGS ARE HAPPENING.G  AMERY
VISIT THE SYNAGOGUE.
THE DI OF THE NA
THE WHITE HOSAWAS N'T HAPPEN
FE PHONE CAL
HE MADTO RABBI OF THE THE RABB E
SAYI TS DID HAPPEN.ESIDENT DENCN
SINT BIDENT TIMEAGAIN, IS
E ON THE HSEOPP
REPUBLANR,CAHIS RECENT
NEWSNT THAT'S JUST
BRANY .  SE INTERVIEAND UNTED  M
HE SAID ESHIES SEEN.T ONLYY
EVELS, THEY WERE
NO BASIS IN FACT.DTAN THAT AGA
EN. W
>> THIS ISTHERE WAS NO GROUP AN
5,000 AERPRISONTH THE U
HERE.
WHERE HAVE WE HEAR EFORE?
IO IT WAS PRID
TRUMP'S OWN DEAL WITH THE
E U.
5,000 AFGHANSONERS